Chương trường tình bảo Irana S. Mai khat tiếp ngày hành này tỏngi một chứ biết
Ké ra nên đối mặt với người cơ sức hiện cả mưu, nhằm vào lãnh tụ tin thần tuổi cao ali khảm ơn chung đào có khả năng tâm công hoặc ấm sát
Quán chính này nâng nhận định rằng các đối tụ của Irana tập trường với yếu tố ăn nền, quòn nhá lãnh đạo tối cao
Bởi đầy được có là chủ cột bảo đam ồn định cho ảnh thống chiến trị, dù không cơm bộ chí tiết, ông cho sang
Các mỗi đi soạn có thể suất phát từ cả bên ngoài là mình trong đến nước
Nhờ quán chính cơ tỏng khá của Yván chục thử sát qua cũng từng để cập đến vuy cơ này
Tổng thống mà sư Phadchist Kinh cho biết trong dụng mời hai ngày bị xerén hồi thẳng sấu
Thế và đánh nhận lo ngại về khả năng sảy ra tận công vào lãnh tụi tuổi cao
Những kệng bảo mới đưa ra trong lúc Yván tích tục trăng cường ăn nền và theo sỏi thông hả đậu bị xem là cám thiệt
Từ các nổng đối định nhằm nâm trận huy cơ bởi đổ ngã sấu